sydney a été récemment dans l'actualité
il ya de cela un an de façon flagrante
puisqu'il a eu l'oscar du meilleur
acteur en 1963 à hollywood sinon
qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu faire un
pari et qu'allez vous faire
je suis à paris pour quelques jours en
route pour l'afrique pour mes vacances
j'étais récemment à berlin où j'étais le
chef de la délégation américaine
présente au festival du film
faisait maintenant prendre quelques
jours de vacances en afrique
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que miriam
makeba a tourné ya de cela quelques
années un film qui s'appelait come back
africa aimeriez-vous et avez vous
l'intention de tourner un film dans ce
genre
je les fais plusieurs fois sur les 21
films que j'ai tournés 16 ou 17 d'entre
eux traiter du problème racial je suis
maintenant fatigué dans ce genre de rôle
je voudrais faire les choses d'autres je
ne voudrais pas que ma carrière d'acteur
est la couleur soit limité à ce genre de
signer en france nous ne connaissons pas
encore votre film pour lequel vous avez
obtenu l'oscar 1963 les leaders de file
parlez nous de ce fil
je pense que l'on verra ce film à paris
au début du mois d'août c'est un bon
film un film tout un film merveilleux et
un film qui ne choquera pas la morale et
que pour en voir des familles entières
il n'y a ni scènes de violence ni scènes
d'amour c'était une gracieux et tendre
comme je vous le disais avant tout un
film image
[Musique]